[Music]
foreign
view a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with the chief
leader writer of The Observers on your
soda and the deputy editor of
conservative home Henry Hill and welcome
to both of you so front pages then let
us start with the Daily Mail boris's
party get accuser faces his own police
probe reads the front of the mail amid
reports that a formal probe has been
launched into a birthday drinks bash
held for sir Bernard Jenkins wife
the Metro has interviewed the first baby
born out of the NHS who says we must
cherish the Health Service as it
celebrates its 75th anniversary tomorrow
cheaper food on the way as a price war
finally Hots out reached the front of
the Daily Express as it looks at
supermarket inflation the front of the
Guardian looks at the government's plans
for global warming with the headline UK
ready to drop an 11.6 billion pound
pledge for a climate fund
the U.S pushes for Wonder lion to be the
next NATO Chief reads the headline in
the Daily Telegraph as they report that
Ben Wallace's candidacy has been blocked
the financial times leading with the
bank of England looking at contentious
plans to force more International Banks
to set up subsidiaries in the UK
and the front page of the Daily Mirror
Has what they say is an exclusive
interview with the broadcaster Fiona
Phillips speaking about her own
Alzheimer's diagnosis
and The star looks at the influence of
popular television shows on politics
what a quick reminder by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
listen to our guests so let's head
straight to them and head to Sonia soda
and Henry Hill
um Henry why don't you kick off for us
then uh Daily Mail front page a couple
of partygate probes by the police
they've picked up on one for sabena
Jenkins who we saw in action today of
course what do you make of their
response to this uh to this news
so this is catnip to Boris Johnson's
supporters uh Burton Jenkins was one of
the senior conservatives on the
Privileges committee that delivered that
damning report into Boris Johnson over
partygate and eventually precipitated
his departure from the House of Commons
and now the police are investigating an
allegedly lockdown-breaking party uh
held by Sir Bernard to celebrate his
wife's birthday now obviously we don't
want to be judge this investigation we
don't know what's going to happen but
sir Bernard's appear reappearance of the
Privileges committee has been his first
public outing in a little while he's
been accused of going to ground for
several weeks and sort of keeping a low
media profile so it definitely obviously
is going to be very uncomfortable for
him personally but it is also
unhelpfully going to give soccer to
Boris Johnson's most committed
supporters who are just on a war path
and out to damage as many people as they
can yeah and that's interesting isn't it
that Boris Johnson's team still feel the
need to do that even though he has
exited stage left
um the other one of course is the mingle
jingle you know a conservative HQ party
you know who does that implicate the
former candidate for London mayor who's
about to be a peer I mean there's all
sorts of questions that continue Sonia
yeah absolutely so there were two events
that the Met police have reopened
investigations into one is this party in
uh it's a legislative take place in
Parliament um that Bernard Jenkins was
allegedly at but the second is of course
and this is what the guardian focus is
on
um a party in conservative party
headquarters
we already had some photographs from
this party but in the last few weeks an
actual video has emerged
um it's pretty extremely controversial
because the former Tory mayoral
candidate Sean Bailey was at that party
um and he was awarded a peerage in Boris
Johnson's recent resignation honors
there's also someone there who was
awarded an Obe and um Sean Bailey's
former campaign Chief is now running the
campaign of another Tory um hopeful to
be uh London mayor so these are people
still very much involved in conservative
politics and the Met police have said
that they're reopening the investigation
into this event as well that the video
provides further Evidence uh the Met
police have apparently got some criteria
that they apply to events
retrospectively from during the pandemic
um it's you know there's got to be sort
of significant evidence of of wrongdoing
flaunting of the rules and they say this
video provides that evidence that they
need what's also interesting is that
they've also said that they have they
aren't yet reopening or opening I should
say
um an investigation into alleged
wrongdoing at checkers by Boris Johnson
and Carrie Johnson they say they they
don't have um enough evidence uh to open
an investigation into that yes all 16 of
them as the guardian points out it also
makes um the front page there too
involving as you said Boris Johnson his
wife Carrie and close friends at Downey
Street and checkers between June 2020
and may 2021 and Henry while we're on
Boris Johnson
um and in fact the peerage's question
that was something that was put to wish
you soon I kept the liaison Committee of
Select Committee heads today and he was
asked specifically about his involvement
in that list Boris Johnson's list and
whether there are questions about it
Rishi sunak making quite clear that he
passes the list on without any
intervention by him but do you think
we'll get more uh on that list to come
out because it was all lost on the day
that brought Johnson you know decided to
quit his seat wasn't it you know do you
think we'll see further investigations
into those people
actually
um yeah it depends on obviously the
evidence that emerges it was the reason
one of the reasons that Boris Johnson's
list was so surprising is that there
were already these question marks over
people like Sean Bailey
um over lockdown rules and so they've
gone forward now it remains to be seen
whether or not new allegations emerge
against anyone or whether any of the
allegations that have already been aired
end up getting taken forward by the
police but really I think the the
extraordinary thing for Richie sunac is
actually that he didn't intervene on
Boris Johnson's resignation honors list
you know as someone who supports the
House of Lords and think it's a valuable
institution and indeed supports the
honor System I think that this was one
last example of Boris Johnson being
extraordinarily Reckless with the
reputation of British institutions I
think it would have been perfectly
reasonable for the prime minister to
hold off on passing on that list it is
only a convention that he passes it on
Boris Johnson is was obviously not prime
minister he can't do anything himself it
is it is all being governed by
convention and conventions can evolve
and instead he's ended up in this really
politically self-inflicted damaging
situation where a couple of days before
the party gate report came in and Boris
Johnson finally blew up Rishi sunak
signed off most of his uh resignation
honest it was a mistake well I mean
Richard you see and I said he was just
following protocol
um and that is what you you have to do
just very quickly Henry we've got you
you know you've got the finger on the
pulse if you like of the Tory membership
how do they feel now about Boris Johnson
and how do they feel Rishi sunak is
doing because it's you know you saw
today on his face on the liaison
committee it's not it's not an easy job
at times and certainly not at the moment
I mean it's definitely not an easy job
so Rishi sooner there's a British thing
is is not polling well with conservative
party activists in our in our monthly
cabinet League table which we published
this morning he had a negative score but
then so did other eight other people who
either are members of the cabinet have
the right to attend cabinet so he wasn't
alone it's not all entirely down to
Rishi I think he's kind of the recipient
as well of just deep bone deep
frustration by conservative activists
that built up over the Johnson
Premiership and the trust Premiership I
guess we can still call it that
um about the lack of progress that's
been made on various conservative goals
but absolutely you know he is struggling
as of Boris Johnson he still has his
hardcore of committed supporters but
when we ran recent questions on Boris
Johnson support for him returning to
Parliament as a Conservative candidate
is still there but it's going down I
think there's a recognition that his
time has passed okay well more
difficulties for the Prime Minister more
controversy too if we look at the lead
story for the guardian Sonia the
government they say is drawing up plans
to drop the UK's flagship 11.6 billion
pound climate and nature funding pledge
as the prime minister is accused of
betraying populations vulnerable to
Global heating so what is the Pledge and
how significant is this
so this pledge is it's a five-year
pledge a five-year commitment that the
UK has made to spend 11.6 billion
between 2021 and 2026 is a contribution
to a global fund that is aimed at
tackling climate change around the world
particularly amongst uh less affluent
Nations and protecting nature and
Wildlife for example protecting forestry
now the UK has always been seen as a
global leader on these sorts of
commitments but the guardian is
reporting uh this evening uh news of an
internal memo between government
departments where essentially this memo
sets out the reasons for why this 11.6
billion is going to be difficult to meet
I think it's incredibly worrying and
also massively self-defeating we know
that climate change is increasingly
going to drive uh migration movements
across the globe as more and more people
aren't able to inhabit where they live
anymore as a result to sort of
catastrophic changes in the climate
um and you know this is this fund is
something that's aimed at helping to
reduce the impacts of global heating uh
worldwide really but particularly
helping less affluent uh Nations reduce
their carbon emissions so it's a really
really important initiative and I think
for the UK to renege would be very very
worrying indeed and when you think about
it 11.6 billion over five years in the
grand scale of government spending it
really isn't that much I mean yes the
guardian pointing out um that the
problem is that
um help for Ukraine Falls within the aid
budget so it's almost impossible to meet
these targets
um and and of course it was a political
some might say decision to cut the aid
budget of the UK Henry
yeah the government cut it from 0.7 to
0.5 of GDP uh on account of the they
they said the enormous pressure on the
public finances and you know ultimately
that's a move there consistently I think
polls well at least with conservative
voters but it does leave them with this
problem this is also just also an
example of classic treasury thinking
right you know you make this big
commitment and then you say that
actually most of you you're going to
spend most of the money in the next
financial period in the next five year
spending round right you'll spend a
little bit of money now but you'll
definitely spend the rest of money later
and then things get tight and the money
gets cut this happens in British
spending and across departments all the
time it's one of the biggest problems
with the way that the British government
handles money in general it's one of the
reasons that hs2 is so expensive is
because everything is shunted into the
future in order to keep the five-year
spending within the treasury's limit so
this is a deeply a deeply unfortunate
development it is it seems like it's
been entirely predictable given that we
know with the government the government
has known what it's spending on Ukraine
it's known that it slashed the headline
budget you know the fcdo will have known
the financial implications of this so
they've they should have seen it coming
but this is not a problem that's unique
to Aid it is not a problem that's unique
to this it is just a symptom of how
badly the treasury manages government
budgets well staying with environmental
issues with financial implications to
the Euless story inside pages of the
Metro uh the London massadiq Khan lacks
the legal power to expand the capital's
ultra low emission Zone this is the
troy-led councils surrounding London
who've brought this case Sonia
so this is looking shaping up to be a
big legal fight between Sadiq Khan on
the one hand who wants to expand the 12
pounds 50 a day charge for vehicles that
don't meet the standards for the ultra
low emission zones so cars that's
actually tough to pay 12 pounds 50 a day
and he wants to extend that zone to the
whole of greater London so it would
cover every London borough and there are
a number of conservative run councils on
the outskirts of London places like
Bromley for example that are challenging
that decision and taking him to court as
to whether he's got the legal power to
do that and I think it remains to be
seen what the outcome of that Court
battle is but the issues at stake are
really really important so on the one
hand you've got the fact that you know
we've got really terrible air pollution
in London we breach kind of legal limits
We Know It's associated with with
illness and deaths for example in
children with asthma and you know it's
really important that we take action and
quite urgent action to reduce to improve
the quality of air in London because it
really does genuinely cost lives on the
other hand it's very unpopular
um you know a 12 pound 50 charge for
polluting vehicles and what the
conservative councils are saying is that
some people can't afford to either pay
that charge or switch to a cleaner
vehicle
um you know my feeling is that it's it's
a sort of necessary evil really we've
got to find a way of bringing air
pollution
um in London down
um but you know this is really turning
into a legal fight about what are the
powers of the mayor does he have the
powers to impose us haven't got time for
a full answer but thumbs up or thumbs
down for this policy Henry
I mean I live in central London a new
public transport all the time so from my
perspective it's obviously fine but if
you live in one of the outer boroughs of
London and your life much more resembles
that of a town where you use your car
all the time I can see why this might be
very challenging um lots of news about
supermarkets this week Daily Express
suggests that supermarkets are waging a
wall to drive down prices on food Sonia
yes this is right so apparently
Sainsbury's has announced that it's
reducing
um the prices of a hundred of its sort
of Key Products
um and it says that it thinks that this
is the start of hopefully falling price
inflation which I think news of which
would come as a huge relief to people up
and down the country who are really
struggling with bills as a result of
higher energy prices higher mortgage
rates and rents and of course higher
food prices
um but this is just the sort of first
sign that food prices might eventually
start to fall
um I think we're a long way from knowing
that that's a dead cert so I think we
should be um cautious before doing too
much celebrating yet let's move on shall
we to the Metro uh once again news about
Thames water after Sky News break the
news uh last week about their financial
difficulties after the exit of their
chief executive Henry at this time find
3.3 million pounds after a sewage spill
killed more than a thousand fish and
turned Rivers black and the Metro
suggesting the company deliberately
attempted to cover up the discharge of
millions of liters of waste into
waterways close to Gatwick Airport
um part of a court hearing and this of
course comes amid great angst amongst
British people about these sewage
discharges that we're seeing
yeah just in case there were sort of
five people left in the country who
thought the Thames water were doing a
good job here we have probably a second
story from the past to remind us that in
fact they've been terrible for ages uh
it is remarkable there's not much detail
in the Metro about the uh the
allegations that they misled the
environment agency and tried to cover it
up but when you read the rest of the
story you can see why they might right
apparently when this over spill happened
there were no alarms in place to alert
staff that there was an over spill and
that all of this water was being
discharged into the river Network when
they finally did discover that there was
a problem they couldn't get in touch
with the lead engineer because the lead
engineer was awaiting delivery of a new
mobile phone and no one had thought to
give them one in the interim just in
case they needed to do their job it's
it's just absolutely remarkable when you
think about the fact that apparently
this is what causes an awful lot of
these issues you know sometimes there
are you know water companies might be
blaming for everything the this country
is still running largely on Victorian
water infrastructure and we don't build
things like reservoirs and so on but
ultimately so many of these leaks which
cause huge environmental damage and also
prevent people from enjoying Rivers
swimming at the beach and stuff like
that you know really important stuff are
down to basic basic failures of systems
the failure to have an alarm the failure
to make sure you can contact your staff
in good time it's not a surprise that
they tried to like mislead the
environment agency if that's what they
did um but yeah they've been caught and
put in the dock I mean I mean it sounds
horrifying doesn't it the the Litany of
mistakes that were made there
um the Metro pointing out the company
has 20 previous fines for pollution the
judge in this case ordering bosses to
put in every effort into tidying up the
problem areas but it feels like
Britain's going backwards on this you
know blue flag beaches we celebrated
each and every one over the over over
several decades Sonia and here we are
you know back to square one on this
really
yeah absolutely and you know Harry
um uh Henry is absolutely right that you
know we've got big big issues with our
infrastructure around water but I think
the way that the industry was privatized
is very much part of that issue so we've
had these privatized um essentially
firms come in that run monopolies over
water in their local area they've had
too few incentives to invest in
upgrading that um that sort of Victorian
infrastructure and um there's been a lot
of private Equity investment and private
Equity investors who've extracted out
profits without making those Investments
and now we've got Thames water a firm
that's loaded up with debt
um you know on the brink of collapse uh
well you've you know it's private Equity
owners have extracted out
um value from the company at the expense
of Bill payers um which is just really
really wrong
so now I'm going to stay with you um if
if you don't mind for the front of the
Daily Mirror which is shattering news to
all her fans Fiona Phillips revealing
that she has Alzheimer's which has
utterly ravaged her family and being
diagnosed a year ago at just the age of
61. so we we certainly spent Center you
know all our very best don't we
absolutely and I I always think it's so
brave when people um speak out publicly
about a diagnosis to sort of help
um share information about it
um uh Fiona Phillips she's a well-loved
uh former gmtv presenter she's a
columnist for the mirror very sadly
Alzheimer's um took the life of both her
mother and her father and they've both
passed away from the disease and one of
the things that she says in her
interview was she you know feared that
she might get the diagnosis but she
thought it might happen to her when she
was around 80 and obviously she received
the diagnosis relatively Young when she
was 61.
um there is some hope in this story
though because she is part of a trial of
a new Alzheimer's drug which doctors and
experts hope will slow the progress of
the disease but it's I mean it's just
such a cruel disease um anyone who's
seen a loved one go through it because
you know it leaves um somebody
physically intact but it removes use
their personality and who they are their
memories and so to watch a loved one go
through it is really really traumatic
and I think it's very brave of her to
talk talk about it openly after it's
clearly um you know had such a big
impact on her family yes my my own
father uh succumbed after 15 years with
Alzheimer's so I you know I fully
understand and she said her mum her dad
her grandparents and her uncle it just
keeps coming back for us so uh you know
huge sympathy certainly for Fiona
Phillips and her family